ready
three two one
[Music]
thick boy
thick light
better do it big you don't live twice
you don't get a chance to do it again
let me show you what the thick light
feels like
thick light
thick nation
big nation you know we do it right never
do
turns out the buttery bros came through
to zoo culture
to lift with your boy and your other boy
and your third boy right there pulling
up behind me so the only question that
remains is
what are we going to do
a little bit of meat and potato
meathead stuff so some bench and then
we're going to end
on more of a crossfit get your heart
rate up
cardio get that form down
bend the bar looks like they're doing
their uh
i don't know there's some meat head
workouts we'll hop in get a little meat
head and then i think we should put like
a
couple of burners really just destroy
their soul i love the gym i like i cry
when i don't come to the gym like i
literally just sit in my room and cry
you know
even though i could just work out in my
backyard i have a kettle bell and jump
rope if i'm not here at zoo culture oh
my [ __ ] day is ruined
[Music]
trying to fix this lower back
in five minutes before we start lifting
[Music]
oh
but for years for like eight or nine
years i was doing like two or three
crossfit style workouts a day
and really like this yeah
and like that's great workouts but i've
had more fun lately just doing
bodybuilding stuff
just training for um you know because i
get my rematch with brendan's shop
you know brendan got me with a
guillotine you know
i switched up my coaches it's no longer
brian callan
uh you know i just you know shouts out
to brian callum but
just what was a good fit
[ __ ] that's a bad idea when i got in
that guarantee and i was like
[ __ ] brian you know what i mean
it was your fault dawg you know so now i
got new coaches
i got meatball you know let's give
meatball a chance but hey once i'm done
with you you're going to be a world
champion it's going to be 500 kid and
you're going to be in the main seat now
brennan i love you but chappelle's home
for you three two one fight
flawless victory
315 chappelle told me he wanted to go
for three
which is a going to be a postcoded pr
nice
good ski good speed
there we go
come on come on come on come on come on
sometimes you gotta get the failures i
always let him go down you gotta show
the failures
you gotta show the failures
because you gotta know you're human
and i am human and i
fail all three of y'all got that
we're going full plate
you're fired up i'm fired up
come on come on come on come on come on
lefty oh
[Music]
it's open for
five coming in here
gotta struggle too
yeah maybe three fifteen's not much
you know what i mean oh yeah so the fact
that they just came and showed up and
blown up on the bench over here we're
gonna make them we're gonna make them
hurt and cross the workout you know the
better they did here was dependent on
how bad that workout is going to be for
them later
i got a lot i got to do you know what
i'm saying i
i can't really uh
crossfit yeah you look you look ready
i'm ready dog
i'm excited okay so this guy's been an
octagon he's ready yeah i mean look at
his ears you're right
you don't wanna mess with huh don't mess
with that guy
okay so we're gonna put 45 on each side
you're gonna sprint down and back when
you cross the line ten burpees tag your
partner and i think it's gonna be teams
of three i started uh film school
you know i'm at the new york film
academy in burbank so
yeah good job guys good job yeah you
just gotta cross that
line down there ready ready
three two one go
[Music]
oh
uh
[Music]
four
five
six
epic
i mean i'm not gonna i don't want to
point anything or serious chappelle but
uh we're we're not in the lead anymore
someone you know
it's on you
show us you want it
guys
come on
come on the velcro shoe should help
let's go push
you got this come on
there you go
let's go big boy let's go big boy
[Music]
how's the doozy man how's the next
little burner
uh
everyone did really good
hey i'll be honest
they are they're fit they're strong
they're a lot of things they're fake
yeah they were doing ufc style burpees
with chess with the deck yeah i thought
that was cool because it was like
it made it more of a race yeah maybe put
on my a-game i was like oh
it's like that let's go
you know we did a typical meathead thing
i think we excelled in that
and then we went into their world
did a little uh circuit slide
burpees we did well we had the lead
there in the second
second round but uh we lost on the
burpees
big boy team technique on the burpees up
that's where we lost it
listen we're a team we don't blame
anybody
it's not about winning
it's about teamwork and there's not one
person to blame
my quads really burning
between
the sled pushes right into the burpees
because you got to get a front squat
motion
going in especially since my back hurts
i'd like get into a full squat to get up
rather than sort of
using my back to get up
so it was time
that was fun i'm glad we did that this
is what i'd like to see right here
chapelle
you've assumed the recovery position
recovery
here's the kind of support you need yeah
right here just here right here
make sure it's okay
catching your breath
starting to come down
that's tough take
how are you man yeah good good good you
guys want to do some burpees now let's
do it yeah
and it was in my hotel room and i have
it on video but i don't know if i was
doing i was jumping but how far are we
going down though
because that's how i made it
oh you know what i'm doing i was trying
to yeah i go i go i go here
damn that's a full burpee now you didn't
i was 47. yeah i did
really i'll do that never happened do
100 right now do 100 for the boys you
know
even for the batteries
that'd be a lot you
there's no stopping you 50. dude you got
the flexible jeans on go yeah i'm on my
magic mind right now you got the adidas
oh my god oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
you're older i'm a little older so hold
on so if this goes south yeah would you
want to give mouth to mouth yeah what
you got you have you have
that he's got a chiseled face yeah that
[ __ ] hair yeah
the commentary you need is like you
don't even need help i don't need your
[ __ ] help there's there's no trains
it might it might get a little gay in
here but congratulations on your [ __ ]
shoulders all right let's go
are you ready i'm i'm attacking right
now at 25 brian i pop the [ __ ] off
here we go
[Music]
let gravity down
[Applause]
[Music]
there we go
that's it
that's a [ __ ] man dragon that's what
the [ __ ] that is
i've done this
yeah that's great
i'm excited for this i'm excited
i'm excited our boy over here is uh
dropping out a new whiskey new blended
whiskey
i was like i gotta give it a try cheers
my man cheers wait
oh that gets a good nose i don't know
what that means but i know uh people
like whiskey that's what they say
yeah sophisticated uh
like leather-bound books and [ __ ]
with the door open oh
that's good like a vanilla note yeah
some some coffee notes are you just
saying the word nope because yeah i feel
like that's what they say yeah i have no
idea what i'm talking about whatsoever
all right what's up everybody we are the
buttery bros out of salt lake city utah
we came in town today to hang out with
brian when we get into mars we got to
hit a bench press session we did a sled
sprint we got to do a bunch of working
out and then we came over here to the
studio got to do the podcast firing the
kid and uh just try to the new whiskey
oh let's not forget about the burpees
and putting up some yeah yeah yeah we're
going to do the workout oh i'm actually
pretty excited it's going to be my first
comedy show ever in the city of malay so
we're going to like a staple where a lot
of people came up michael king came up
here we're going to run the show tonight
check it out just know though we still
be trying to work out though
you had half burpees
what's up guys hope you enjoyed watching
the buttery bros
fake boy's ass at zoo culture we got him
on the strength side though you saw we
were doing work on the bench but when it
got to the cardio
side of things yellow dicey
barrel
i want point
[Music]
uh and then those boys got to go to the
improv i invited the show uh at the
improv and they got to see theo vaughn
eric griffin chris dylan myself there's
a hell of a show if you guys haven't
checked out the buttery bros go watch
them on their youtube they post vlog
rolling freaking time they're crushing
it and then the big announcement this
saturday calabasas fight companion we
back baby got brian callum crystalia my
thick ass and special guest my brother
from another mother the host of
ridiculousness the man the myth the
legend the street skating legend himself
rob darridan that's right calves fight
pain for ufc 269 is this saturday only
live
big boy youtube 7 p.m pacific tune in
ufc 269 cowboys fight companion let's
get it
[Music]